ognuno di noi vive in una bolla nel
lavoro ci sono tutte le informazioni che
riescono
certo un tempo di informazioni ce
n'erano poche non c'era il problema di
raggiungerli ma piuttosto di trovarle
però con giornali radio televisioni
in realtà le informazioni sono diventate
moltissime quindi avuto un ruolo chiave
quello dell'editore che filtra e ordina
per rilevanza tutte queste informazioni
noi quindi dobbiamo solo scegliere la
linea editoriale a cui ci sentiamo più
vicini e con questa popolare la nostra
buona dell'informazione trovate queste
bolle sono condivise quindi con un gran
numero di che altre persone
negli ultimi 10 15 anni questo panorama
però è cambiato sia alla creazione di
notizie sia la fruizione hanno
beneficiato della rivoluzione digitale
quindi adesso le notizie sono di fatto
letteralmente infinite e il modo di
fruire anche incluso fare delle ricerche
su internet andare su dei siti di
aggregazione di news oppure sui nostri
sui nostri social network
questo nuovo paradigma al trigono
dell'editore è stata superata da una
figura nuova quella del mali colizzi
l'algoritmo è quello che riesce in
questa infinita di informazioni a
scegliere ordinare per rilevanza le
informazioni utili matter ognuno di noi
singola allora facciamo un passo dietro
le quinte vediamo che cosa c'è come sono
fatti questi questi angoli qui con un
disclaimer allora le aziende grandi
città di naturalmente hanno in questi
auguri qui i loro asset quindi sono
segretissimi e e complicatissimi quello
che discutiamo qui sono i meccanismi di
base in una forma super semplificata
però credo che possano tornare utili
comunque per capirne poi gli effetti sta
diventando in via gorini sono dei
software però proviamo ad immaginarci e
fisicamente che più facile come dei
cervelli e dei green day cepellini di
gomma nascono neutri ma possono essere
addestrati dagli sviluppatori per
raggiungere un certo obiettivo grazie a
un meccanismo
facciamo un esempio facile abbiamo
cervellino veniamo a testarlo a
riconoscere con gli animali sono
rappresentati di immagini allora gli
diamo so immagine di un detto e lui
all'inizio i neuroni sono disposti
casualmente quindi la prima volta
potrebbe classificavano in qualunque
modo
era una prossimità come un cane a quel
punto io gli dico guarda ha sbagliato
questo era un fatto i neuroni grazie a
questo film si riconfigurano se li
ripropongo la fotografia questa volta
nella classifica correttamente come
gatto c'è la stessa cosa tutti gli altri
animali so io propongo un cavallo magari
il cervellino della classifica come
gatto il lido il feedback è sbagliato i
neuroni si configurano nuovamente quando
il cavallo vivamente correttamente se io
li faccio questo processo per tante
centinaia di migliaia di volte alla fine
quello che ho è un algoritmo addestrato
a riconoscere gli animi quindi quello
che ritiene che volevamo dire
ed è esattamente questo stesso modello
che viene utilizzato nell'ambito delle
informazioni vediamo in che modo si
applica questo allora abbiamo detto che
l'obiettivo delle aziende digitali e
tenere ognuno di noi incollato allo
schermo non lasciarci andare emilia ero
dall'altra parte quindi l'obiettivo con
cui vengono addestrati questi algoritmi
e trovare insieme di infinito di
informazioni proprio quelle giusto per
tenere ognuno di noi il incollato agli
schermi e insieme glielo diamo noi
inconsapevolmente quando ci propongono
delle notizie noi possiamo semplicemente
passare oltre e questo è un feedback
negativo il cervellino al cervellino
viene trovata è scelto male questa
notizia non va bene per quella persona
oppure possiamo germain e commentarle in
tal caso il feedback arcieri naughty
bear rafforzativo buono questa è il tipo
di notizie giuste per questa persona
naturalmente questo ha fatto con ognuno
di noi ha replicato centinaia di
migliaia di volte tutta la comunità
degli utenti fa sì che questi gemellini
siano man mano sempre più capaci di
scegliere per ognuno di noi
singolarmente proprio le notizie che
vogliamo
a questo proposito voglio prendere a
prestito alla definizione di ieri parsa
uno speaker di ted che definisce queste
notizie le notizie zuccherino e mi piace
molto questa definizione perché sono
proprio quelle più che si mangiano più
facilmente
più facili da leggere che ci viene
voglia di aprire quando vediamo perché
perché non eri solo buste sono curiose
oppure tratta degli argomenti che già
conosciamo conservano un'opinione che
già abbiamo e quindi sono più facili
quello che dice anche lì parser e
rischiamo in questo modo però di
rinunciare a una dieta informativa forse
un pochino più faticosa però anche più
equilibrato dove ci sia nei semi plateau
e l'informazione
questo è uno dei due effetti collaterali
importanti questi tipi di soluzioni va
sotto il nome di effetto filtro cosa
succede che a fronte di una eterogeneità
informazioni possibili
io finisco a continuare a ricevere
notizie solo sugli argomenti su cui so
che già a conoscenza e che non venga
data l'opportunità nuovi stimoli nuovi
spunti interessanti di entrare nella mia
villa
lasciando quindi fuori tutto
l'arcobaleno e colorando la mia bolla
soltanto di un unico torio questo
montario re brutto effetto collaterale
che siccome avevo detto sono molto
personali questi questi algoritmi è
facile che io incontri altre persone la
cui bolla ha un colore completamente
diverso cercando di dialogare
si cerca un terreno comune per costruire
un dialogo costruttivo diventa molto
difficile perché partiamo ovviamente da
due rappresentazioni del mondo molto
diverse l'una dall'altra una data dalla
propria dalla propria bomba secondo
effetto collaterale serio e noto come
effetto eco e deriva dal tipicamente da
quando ci si informa tramite social
network no se in una cerchia di amici
sono molti appassionati di una tematica
estremamente probabile che in quella
cerchia quella tematica venga rimbalzata
più e più volte dall uno all altro una
specie di effetto eco e quindi che ci
fornisca una percezione distorta della
sua effettiva diffusione è su questo che
racconta una storia io vengo dalla
pellice e un posto vicino alla valle di
susa dove c'è il cantiere del tunnel ad
alta velocità no la tav verso nuovo
verso la francia
una decina d'anni fa direi
ho cominciato a interessarmi
e quindi lì a cercare attivo invece le
cose nel giro di due tre settimane
il mio mondo digitale sia il più
popolato di un sacco di informazioni
anche molto interessanti articoli link
commenti
tanto che io faccio la confessione mi
sono detta ingenuo ma guarda mi sono
informata appena in tempo
quando il il tema è ripetuto il centro
del dibattito pubblico per male perché
così adesso sono sono più informata
quando poi la mattina vado a fare
colazione al bar muto l'occhio sui
quotidiani di indisponibili e nessuna
delle prime pagine si parlava della
tavola un condiviso al punto ma davanti
non si parlava dal termine anche nelle
pagine successive e non c'era nemmeno un
trafiletto nella cronaca cittadina della
provincia di torino
cioè ero caduta in questo tranello e
hanno perso la consapevolezza di queste
due dimensioni distinte una cosa io
ritengo importante e cosa ritengono
importante i miei amici e l'altra qual è
la reale diffusione di un'amicizia nella
popolazione
quindi bisogna stare un po attento in
questo questo effetto eco sono due
notizie positive
uno è che i giganti dell'informazione
digitale sempre molto sensibili a cosa i
clienti cose clienti desiderano si sono
resi conto che con queste notizie
zuccherino le persone cominciamo un po
tutti forse ad avere la sensazione che
si sono piacevoli ma poi forse perdiamo
tanto tempo dietro cosi rilevanti e
finiamo per non raggiungere l'obiettivo
per cui ci siamo connessi di fatto che è
informarci e quindi costruirci una
visione più fedele possibile del mondo
del momento di bibbiano e quindi questi
giganti dell'informazione online stanno
lavorando per rendere questi algoritmi
tali da non cadere più i costi tra la
notizia ancora più bella è che noi sin
da subito possiamo fare qualcosa in
questa direzione in realtà basta un
piccolo sforzo e un pochino in salita
però dovremo provare a cercare
informazioni che senza aspettare che
vengano loro da noi un po diverse dal
solito
magari approfondire punti di vista un
pochino diversi con persone che la
pensano un po di versante
noi che ci propone una cosa che esulano
di tutti già la conosciamo e poi forte
dalla mia esperienza precedente
mantenere sempre un occhio
all'editoriale plastica in modo da non
cadere il mio tranello avere delle volte
di torino tradizionali che ci diano
sempre la percezione di quant'è la
diffusione effettiva che l'informazione
a livello del mondo della popolazione la
domanda adesso è ma perché dovremmo fare
questo sforzo già facciamo dalla tattica
fare tante altre cose
io credo che allora intanto nelle nostre
opinioni non possano che beneficiare di
una bolla di una eterogeneità di notizie
e di informazioni che quindi possono
portarci a vendere le nostre riflessioni
anche più ricche più approfondite una
società con le volte più colorate a una
società più incline al dialogo
io lavoro nell'innovazione credo
profondamente che il progresso dipenda
tanto dal dubbio dal dissenso dalla
discussione dal costruire qualche cosa
di nuovo e quindi penso che una società
con bolle molto colorate possa essere
potenzialmente una società molto più
ricca e che possa fare molto meglio del
progresso e penso anche che una società
dove si possa dialogare serenamente e
intavolare delle discussioni costruttive
sia anche una società dove sarà più
bello vincere grazie